Taylor Swift has dropped the music video
for her latest single the man both the
song and video take on double standards
between men and women us with her past
videos this one is full of Easter eggs
and other hidden meanings here's a look
at everything you missed every video
from Swift's lover era has started with
her by a window and the man is no
different except now we have Tyler Swift
the office season looks similar to the
one from Swift's bad blood music video
instead of a fight scene between women
this time we get a recreation of the
wolf of Wall Street
Swift's alpha male persona Tyler mimics
Leonardo DiCaprio's Jordan Belfort Tyler
takes the scene a step further by fist
bumping and acknowledging only the men
in the room the leo reference is no
coincidence either but more on him later
next we see Tyler manspreading on a
subway train behind him are some fake
advertisements parroting the overtly
violent in sexual ways in which the
media portrays met the one seemingly
advertising for liquor reads capitalize
on the feeling this is likely a
reference to how Swift's been criticized
and called calculated for writing about
her relationships the word greedy is
written on the train wall so it's been
called greedy in the past for certain
business decision she's made like
adopting a fan verified ticket sale
system for her reputation stadium tour
and pulling her music catalog from
streaming services like Spotify and
Apple music / artist royalty disputes
but there's a whole other take we can
read it from this poster in the word
greedy the title boss Scotch seems to be
a play on words referring to her old
record label boss Scott Borchetta and a
post on tumblr last June so I've shared
how she felt betrayed by Bush at a sale
of her music to talent manager Scooter
Braun this poster could be a call out to
bruschetta as greedy for capitalizing on
Swift's body of work which famously
features her own feelings and
experiences let's take a look back at
the movie poster man vs. disaster the
fake title could reference the action
from trope that all it takes is one man
to save the day in contrast Swift has
often been said to be playing the victim
when she tries to fight industry giants
like record labels and streaming
services one of the fellow train
passengers is wearing a Miss Americana
in the heartbreak print sweatshirt
straight from Swift's actual merch line
miss Americana is another song from
lover that deals with themes of sexism
and misogyny looking back to the movie
poster
see the date July 20th does this mean
miss Americana could be a single in the
summer of 2020 Tyler opens a newspaper
and the cover story asks what man won
the year in celebrity dated this
headline calls out the double standard
that criticizes women but celebrates men
for dating round Swift herself is
somewhat of a poster child for this
double standard and has spoken out
against him many times in the past Tyler
exits the train onto a platform and
pauses to take a leak
he's not 13th Street Station not just
Swift's lucky number 13 which we've seen
referenced many times before in past
videos the wall Tyler stops at is
covered in graffiti with the names of
Swift's past albums like reputation red
and 1989 she's hidden easter eggs
through graffiti before and many of her
reputation era videos like ready for it
and delicate we also see the word karma
and graffiti which we've heard swift
used before in her classic song look
what you made me do a sign says missing
if found returned to Taylor Swift and
another one symbolizes no scooters the
posters in graffiti are another
reference to her ongoing battle with
Scooter Braun and Scott Borchetta over
the Masters of all of the albums we see
on the wall Tyler is peeing on the wall
could represent how the two men and men
in the music industry in general have
disrespected swifty throughout her
career there's also a poster for mr.
Americana directed by Larry Wilson
comparing up man dance and documenting
Tyler Swift Taylor Swift's own
documentary miss Americana directed by
Lana Wilson premiered at Sundance
earlier this year when speaking to
Glamour about making the film
Wilson recalled how she and her
all-female crew were often not taken
seriously because of their gender this
riff on the documentaries poster also
relates to the fact that Swift directed
this music video for the man her
impressive credits for the song and
video
that's songwriter performer executive
producer video director and star to be
clear come at a time when music film and
other entertainment industries are being
heavily criticized for their lack of
opportunities and recognition for women
as Tyler steps away from the subway wall
we see the man written out in
well it's glittery and blue which looks
pretty similar to Swiss love our
aesthetic having the man written in blue
glitter it could also be Swiss way of
saying men just like women can be
complex and aren't limited to the narrow
definition of masculinity society pushes
on them next Tyler's on a yacht if it
looks familiar that's because it's
another nod to the wolf of Wall Street
the movie not only embodies the sexist
double standard so if calls out in the
man but its star Leonardo DiCaprio is
specifically named checked in the lyrics
I'd be just like leo in San Tropez
DiCaprio is well known for dating a
number of women especially younger
models and in the man so it makes a
point of emphasizing how men like
DiCaprio get more of a legend status for
this type of dating whereas women like
herself are criticized for their dating
habits we see swift call out double
standards again as Kylie leaves what
looks like a one-night stand instead of
having the walk of shame that's assigned
to women he struts through what looks
like more of a Hall of Fame 19 hands
high-five him there the 19 hands we saw
on the song's promotional photo 19 is a
number Swift's been highlighting since
even before the video was announced
during her woman of the decade
acceptance speech at the Billboard Music
Awards Swift mentioned 19 other female
artists by name the references to the
number are likely a nod to the 19th
amendment which gave the first group of
women the right to vote in the US the
amendments ratification is seen as a
landmark win in the women's rights
movement in American history Swift also
released the man on February 27th this
is the anniversary of when the Supreme
Court dismissed a challenge to the
amendment and unanimously agreed that
the right to vote could not be denied on
the basis of sex and if the hallway
looks familiar it could be because it
resembles the one from Kanye West's
distinctly sparse home you might recall
that West's infamously interrupted a 19
year-old Taylor Swift at the 2009 VMAs
and Swift's not just throwing shade at
West here her reference is pretty
significant under the context of the man
when West interrupted her award speech
he implied that her work wasn't
deserving enough of it years later when
West's reference whipped and his song
famous he rapped I made that famous
West behavior is a clear example of men
devaluing or even straight-up taking
credit for a woman's work this reference
seems even more purposeful after a scene
in Miss Americana that shows Swift
writing the man with droll little she
throws out some lyric ideas saying we'd
be popping bottles to the and models and
the hoes cuz they get to call us that
which is exactly what West did in the
next scene Tyler's being celebrated as
the world's greatest dad
after seemingly doing the bare minimum
with his child the scene address is
another double standard where single
moms rarely get any recognition or as
their male counterparts are praised for
little effort if you look closely you
can also see that while Tyler as
manspreading again his daughter isn't
which could be showing how girls are
taught from a young age to take up less
space also catch a brief cameo from
social media star Dominic Tolliver and
actress Statham bartels we next see
Tyler partying in a bar with other men
they throw around money as they take
body shots off of women referencing the
reduction of women to objects and being
valued only for their bodies the money
they throw around has Tyler's face on it
a pretty obvious comment two men owning
more money because of the gender pay
gaps and a straight-up lack of
opportunities for women the men are all
wearing matching gold rings which looks
similar to fraternity or other club
rings this could be referencing the boys
club culture in many industries
especially the music industry next up
Tyler is playing a match of tennis we
can spa a Taylor Swift merch water
bottle under the bench this scene seems
to reference a specific incident with
Serena Williams when she was fined
$17,000 for code violations of the 2008
teen US Open Williams argued with the
umpire and slammed her racket on the
ground during a match she said her
actions were due to her feeling that the
umpire was unfairly penalizing her with
his calls
Serena's situation relates to Swift's
recent comment to CBS Sunday morning
when she said the man can react a woman
can only overreact in the music video
Tyler is given a similar pass he throws
a tantrum gets hysterical smashes his
racquet and fights at the umpire and no
one doesn't thing not the ball girl
who's actually tick-tock star Lauren
gray or even the umpire played by
Swift's own father Scott this could
symbolize how people do notice men
acting childish and emotional but they
don't face the same backlash that woman
do and often for even lesser behavior
58 years later a very aged Tyler is
getting married to a much younger woman
five plus E is of course thirteen the
scene shows a stereotypical marriage
between a super old guy and a younger
girl as the bride flashes her giant ring
it's likely she'll be painted the bad
guy and labeled a gold digger the light
pink flower on Tyler's lapel looks like
the Cornelia flowers Swift's been using
throughout her lover era promo and also
references the album's track Cornelius
tree we've seen a wedding and cake
smashing in a lover era video before and
you need to calm down there's an epic
cake fight after a same-sex marriage
Swift could be drawing parallels to
society's acceptance of what might be
called a non-traditional marriage with a
large age gap over one between two
people of the same sex the scene also
begs us to imagine the reverse if an
older woman were marrying a younger man
she'd be the one criticized for
cradle-robbing in any case it's the
straight man who's getting off easy as
the epic video comes to an end Swift
reverses gender roles one last time we
hear Swift as the video's director
yelled cut and Tyler walks off set
he has slipped about his performance but
the voice we hear is actually the rocks
Swift tells him to be sexier maybe more
likable she then praises Lauren for her
outstanding work really she's just been
standing around in the background it's
with slash dig at the ridiculous and
sucks the standards in the entertainment
industry mermen are showered with praise
and awards often for doing the bare
minimum while women are constantly asked
to do better by well by being sexier and
more likeable the man is a funny but
poignant take on several of the double
standards women face and the larger
systems that enforce them Swift lover
era has seen her becoming more vocal
about politics and if this video is any
indication she's only getting started